Affairs Eric Shinseki that was some of
the conference from earlier today and
now Vice President Biden and Veterans
Affairs Secretary Eric Shinseki wrapping
up today's White House Conference on
mental health it's good to see all of
you what a what a good day this has been
this summit has enabled a crucial
much-needed national level discussion on
mental health at VA at the Department of
Veterans Affairs we know that when we
are able to diagnose and treat people
get better and the president knows that
too so between 2009 and 2014 he has
requested funding increases for VA
mental health totaling almost 57% thanks
to the president's strong and decisive
leadership VA has expanded its services
as a number of veterans needing mental
health care has increased and he
announced some of those accomplishments
just this morning 24 pilot projects with
federally qualified community clinics of
nine States increasing our mental health
capacity through partnering at the local
level local mental health summits to be
conducted at each of our 152 VA medical
centers broadening the dialog between
clinicians and stakeholders and then
finally over 1,600 additional mental
health clinical professionals hired as a
result of the executive order he signed
last August with his leadership and the
leadership of Vice President Biden and
the support of the Congress VA will
continue to improve access to mental
health services and reduce the stigma of
seeking help now one of our most
effective efforts to improve access has
been our Veterans Crisis Line which
provides immediate help the veterans and
servicemembers in distress in the past
six years the Veterans Crisis Line has
answered over 800,000 phone calls and
over a hundred thousand other online
chats chats and text messages
in the most serious of those phone calls
29,000 veterans have been rescued from a
suicide in progress because we were
there for them partnering with local
communities and other federal agencies
can help make the most of our resources
like the Veterans Crisis Line and the
additional 1600 clinical professionals
and by working together we can reduce
the stigma for all Americans
everyone can help and everyone must if
we are to make the difference as the
president emphasized this morning now
we're indebted to all of you for the
great work you do and now special thanks
to our next speaker
Bradley Cooper whose authentic portrayal
of the character Pat solatano and silver
linings playbook helped to shine a
spotlight on both the challenges and the
triumphs of those who are dealing with
issues of mental health so that Bradley
thank you thank you very much secretary
Shinseki for that introduction and for
all that you're doing to address mental
health issues to our veterans it is well
whata privileged me to be here today I
have a chance to participate in this
conference it's been a fascinating day
it's obviously an important day and I'm
very thankful to be a part of it the
truth is I'm sort of here by accident
it's not that I didn't know about mental
illness I think it's that I just didn't
see it as a part of my own life I didn't
really think that it affected me it was
a sort of abstract idea that I was
removed from and then I did this movie
called silver linings playbook and it
was really as if a veil had been lifted
I realized that people that I knew
people that I loved and care about they
were they were coping with this in
silence one of my closest friends was
bipolar and I just I really had no idea
people I was working with on the film
that children and they had parents who
were struggling with this and it really
just never occurred to me and you know I
had the good fortune of playing a
character who caused to change my mind
in the sense that people would come up
to me and share their struggles telling
me how they connected with this
character that I played and I think
that's what helped me to see that I
think that all of us are touched in a
real meaningful way with this illness
and I think it is up to all of us to
help and I want to help I want to do
something about it I want to be a part
of the solution and
and as it turns out as I learning that
has been reiterated today that the way
we can do that is to talk about it to
bring awareness to it it's about helping
people understand that they're just
they're not alone that the thing that
they're feeling it probably has a name
it certainly has a treatment and that
treatment works and it's effective and
it can change the way that they live
their lives and ways that they probably
thought weren't even possible and in a
lot of ways it's about helping people
find the courage in themselves to take
that step to seek treatment and that's
partly by raising awareness about the
availability and the quality of that
treatment in today's conference has been
such an important part of that effort
but I think we also have to make some
fundamental changes to our culture you
know it's always going to take courage
for people dealing with mental illness
to seek treatment but it shouldn't take
that much courage as it does today it
just shouldn't it's less about the
people who are dealing with the illness
and it's more about the people who
aren't it's about the rest of us who can
work together to D stigmatize these
issues to feel a genuine empathy and to
take meaningful action your final
speaker today understands that very well
I had the honor of spending some time
with Vice President Biden in February
and we talked about mental health issues
about the importance of reversing
negative negative stigmas and negative
attitudes and about the actions that
this administration has been taking to
make sure mental health care is
affordable and available to all
Americans he's been a very strong
advocate for mental health parity a
great friend of the mental health
community and the kind of leader that
this moment requires ladies and
gentlemen the vice president of the
United States Joe Biden
please place it down well good afternoon
my name is Joe Biden I'm her friend of
Bradley Cooper's how many of you saw
silver linings playbook now let me tell
you after I saw it I called and asked
whether or not to come in and see me the
director as well and I I just think you
know sometimes art many times art has a
more profound impact
Hey how you doing buddy good come here
come here
this guy's got a program going on to
deal with the only Uncharted part of the
world the human brain and it is a
gigantic initiative and he with his
cousin there's always doing good things
and doing great great work if Timmy
Schreiber ahead and the reason he says
that if he doesn't say that about his
cousin he'll never hear the end of
that's right not from his cousin but
from all those drivers and anyway I want
to thank you good to see you thank you
and you see general Chiarelli for start
I have to roll let our efforts in Iraq
and is now leading our efforts from one
mind for research thank you
anyway before I so rudely interrupted
myself I apologize
i him by the way this is general who
when I one of my first of my 20-some
trips to Iraq he had it the first calf
and he was in gave me the single best
advice about Iraq of anyone I met with
we met in the middle of what was not a
very friendly time in downtown Baghdad
and and it's great to see you this is a
man who came home realized and I mean it
sincerely realized the in his role back
at the Pentagon how many tens of
thousands potentially of young women and
men coming back from multiple
deployments needed to help and devoted
his life to this now and so this guy is
a warrior a physical warrior and now
warrior for making sure that his
warriors are taken care of
electrum back to Bradley Cooper
so I went home and I said to my to my
daughter married lady to my four
granddaughters I said look I said
Bradley Cooper came in to see me today
I mentioned the guy directed film they
didn't want to hear anything about that
and so it made me sort of a hero
well--that's once you know he caused me
great pain recently I am I've been asked
by the president to sort of lead a new
initiative God willing in the hemisphere
in Latin America to really begin to
change the way we we interact with the
rest of the hemisphere and I went down
to meet with the new Brazilian president
and I'm in my hotel room when we as we
check in my youngest granddaughter had
two granddaughters were with me who were
traveling with my wife going to the
favelas there's really slum areas of
Brazil and Bradley knows about that he
was visited as well and my youngest
granddaughter says pop said Bradley
Cooper's in this hotel and I said you're
kidding me
I said that's nice she said pop you're
his friend right swear to God
swear to God
this is my twelve-year-old I said well
yeah we're kind of French season will
pop you oughta call her and I said what
do you want me to do he said pop we got
just barely big sweet and he said you
should have him down like you do other
people like you have presidents and
things come and see and I said swear to
god you story I said well honey I've got
to go meet the president Brazil and
you're going to follow shortly she said
pop that's all just look pop I said
honey I've got to go to the meeting okay
pop I'll see you
well Bradley somehow we're gonna have to
make up for this you owe me but I my
standing with my granddaughter has
plummeted even though my standing with
the president Brazil has gone up like
that given the choice I'm not sure what
does know is kind of a tough kind of a
tough deal
look speaking of warriors Eric Shinseki
general Shinseki is a guy he's always
spoken truth to power and he did it in
the Afghan war I me excuse me in the
Iraqi war he accurately stated what the
facts were and and he had the courage to
do it and he got a lot of heat for it
and the one of the best decisions the
president made was asking him to head up
the Veterans Administration and
and we all know no one knows better than
Eric that there's real problems we have
real backlogs because we've reached out
so far as we should have been doing the
last 25 years for people who are
suffering from PSD people with traumatic
brain injury and it's created a serious
serious backlog but the thing I know
about the general is he and I agree we
only have one truly sacred obligation is
only one truly sacred obligation and
that is to equip those we send to war
and to care for them when they come back
in their families and we have a lot more
to do as the general will tell you and I
want to thank is Ron Barber still here
is he up voting Ron wherever you are
thank you man thank you very much
he would be such a champion of mental
health first day ladies and gentlemen
I just want to say a few words the close
of the conference has been along and I
hope very fruitful endeavor for you all
you all know the most vulnerable age for
mental health problems in young women
and men between the ages of 16 and 25 I
have a son-in-law who is a
reconstructive plastic surgeon working
most like Katherine on cancer patients
but he also has his PhD in neuroscience
which he said was a lot harder to get
than his medical degree and I asked him
what he did ste Sesana he said I did in
my thesis on the development of neural
pathways for adolescence and what
impacts upon their actually said you
know he said he calls me Papa said you
know pop what we found out is what we
know is that the those neural pathways
really aren't stamped until you get to
between the ages of 18 and 25 he said
and that is most difficult period as I
know all of you know and it's also we
have a large number of that generation
the 9/11 generation as well coming back
from from very very difficult
circumstances and work with a lot of
a lot of invisible injuries we count
every single day I get a I have my card
as to the Defense Department knows I
asked my staff to listen to me every
single day am I on my my schedule the
number of troops who died in Iraq and
Afghanistan by the day by the day every
morning and the number of wounded in
Afghanistan
six thousand five hundred and eighty two
dead as of this morning at seven o'clock
wounded fifty thousand eight hundred and
thirty two but they're all the visible
ones doesn't count all the invisible
wounds so the need for what you're all
about
is going to increase as time goes on
both these groups represent folks that
are the most in need of help and both
are among the least likely to seek out
that help and even if they seek it out
sometimes as you know it's difficult to
find as we all know they're not only
they're not the only Americans living
with mental illness who need help but
what's most encouraging is that there
are also many living with mental illness
who recognize it and they've gone and
gotten help and as Bradley's pointed out
and it works it's worked they are the
best living testament to the need for
and the efficacy the efficacy of seeking
this help but the most important thing
is they recognized they needed help and
they went out and sought it and that's
what everyone everyone needs to
understand it's okay to seek help and
general Chiarelli will tell you I had a
son in Iraq for a year and he came back
and his mom was so anxious to see him
he'd been gone for a year and when he
got back he was at Fort Dix and my wife
was ready to literally climb the
chain-link fence with barbed wire on it
to get to see him but there's a program
now and this was almost just over two
and a half years ago to try to condition
all of his unit
coming back to say why are you having
any problems you having nightmares are
you concerned do you have water your
dreams like are you having trouble
remembering things because these guys
are trained to be warriors these women
are trained to be warriors they're not
trained because to seek help is to
acknowledge weakness sort of completely
contrary to their ethic that they all
possess well young people also are and
then they feel invulnerable invincible
but when they have held it's awful hard
time to go ask for it so what all of us
are doing here today matters a great
deal and it's my hope that this
conference began to makes clear to all
Americans that there's no distinction
let me says there's no distinction
between a mental health problem and a
physical problem that there should be
there is but there should be no stigma
to a family or individual to seek help
for mental health any more than they
would have for a broken arm or a
diagnosis of cancer and in the process
in the process it's our goal to improve
not only the access to mental health
care at an affordable rate but in the
process which you're not talked about
much today I don't think is improving
the already positive positive help
that's out there it begins by making
sure insurance companies provide
coverage to mental health services so
that's affordable and available and
that's what we've done through the
Affordable Health Care Act by the way
that's the mental parity Act that your
dad your dad championed for so long with
pete Domenici established a while ago
but now only only coming to fruition
it's going to ensure the the Affordable
Care Act mnsure the sixty-two million
Americans get quality mental health care
and substance abuse coverage now we're
working to implement the mental health
parity law and as so we can make mental
illness as treatable as all other
illnesses and now we have to season the
opportunity to provide a
they expanded care to make sure that
people in need of help know it's
available in a faith in its efficacy
you know there's mothers as I speak
right now and fathers in this country
with a 17 year old son or daughter who
they know they know needs help they know
needs help that physical they know
there's something wrong it's intuitive
they know it but they don't know where
to go and they're almost afraid to say
something because if they do they're
afraid it ends up in the kids record but
somewhere it's in writing and that's
gonna mean maybe that won't get into
Georgetown and I know my friend dr. -
joy - joy is here
they're afraid maybe they won't get that
job
they fraid they maybe won't be able to
join the military they're afraid by
getting the help they're somehow going
to stigmatize their child we need to
change all that I know you all this is
preaching to the choir we also need to
expand the availability of the personnel
psychiatric nurses psychiatrist
psychologist because we know there's an
enormous gap between the number of
trained personnel we have and the number
we need according to HHS we need about
8,000 more mental health professionals
for be ashame think of the irony here if
for your great efforts we encourage
people to come forward and they find out
there's no one there to help them or
they have to wait a long time last
August the president directed the VA to
hire 1,600 mental health professionals
by June of 2013
today VA announced that it met that goal
but we're also proposing
this isn't a government salute we're
also proposing to provide funding for
schools to train more than 5,000 mental
health professionals we need more than
that we need more than that to serve
young people in their schools and
communities those of you who are mental
health providers know there's a reason
why more people haven't gone into mental
health fields doctors psychiatric nurses
because because that many people asked
people go where the need is almost every
doctor or nurse I've ever known if
there's any angels in heaven by the way
they're all nurses mrs. Pico no guy with
two craniotomies because the manager
isn't one embolism doctors allow you to
live narses make you want to live and I
don't know know they make male nurses
and female nurses I love my my
neurosurgery would command the ICU which
I was in for 60 days for two months and
he's saved we got to do this this is the
other and my nurses it all going yes sir
and then they do exactly what I needed
you think I'm joking those of you had
significant help Medical know that but
here's the point it's not just about
getting more experts in the field it's
about developing new and emboldened
strategies for mental health screening
make it more routine there's more than
one way as my grandma's to say to skin a
cat one way to get someone in to get
mental health is to eliminate the stigma
which we know is going to take some time
another way is to give them cover I
found generals and axis colleague of
yours general and yours
retired Major General of regular General
United States Army and a psychiatrist
serving for 28 years the United States
Army I find an interesting conversation
I'm no expert in this but I met with him
and along with the general and others
who are devoting their lives to making
sure we get more help and more awareness
he suggests that that integrating mental
health screening and ordinary
examinations as a way to lessen the
stigma and recognize the need it's a
hell a lot easier for that soldier or
that 19 year old kid to win while he's
getting his physical - also at the same
time beginning mental health screening
be made aware of it but it's not on
Israeli went to get a physical medical
groups such as the AMA and the American
Psychiatric Association have made
commitments to help train all doctors
and nurses to recognize the signs of
mental illness which is consistent with
providing which doctors are supposed to
do in nurses and they do the health of
their patients so folks we have to
become more imaginative it just can't be
a straight line we've proposed a new
hundred and thirty million dollar
initiative admittedly it came out of the
whole tragedy in Newtown but all the
psychiatrist's I met with I met with
many of them it meant with the
Psychiatric Association's as well they
say there are certain signs there like
Roman candles that go off when you're
six seven eight ten twelve years old
that anyone recognizing that particular
action would know say that child needs
so I'm not able to provide it but that
child needs help so many so many people
could be saved if we recognize just like
cancer you wrecked earlier you recognize
it the greater the possibility so we
propose we teach we state and local
governments teach keep my wife's a
full-time professor she gets a classes
in CPR she gets classes in first aid we
should be teaching educating our
educators to be able to recognize not
all forms of mental illness but those
things are like the Roman candles that
go off that are totally inconsistent
with any behavior that is considered to
be appropriate the earlier we get this
help the better we'll all be and the
better
most of
the patient will be and we know that we
can learn a great deal more
as I said introducing Patrick the only
uncharted purse totally uncharted
portion of the universe is the brain you
know I had as we used to say in the
Senate excuse the point of personal
privilege here I I had to cranially
aneurysms and they literally had to take
the top of my head off I mean they take
a saw and they cut your head off and and
go in to find the artery that is one was
leaking the other that hadn't before it
burst there's this those of your Doc's
know there's a ever every procession
every profession has their sick jokes a
joke among bomb docs is how do you know
someone said a Nanuet cranial aneurysm
on the autopsy table only 20% of the
people haven't even get to the table
well one of the fascinating things is of
the second operation after the first one
which was a bleed and they gave me a
relatively low chance of surviving
I remember going down the dock asking
the doc and we you know you're counting
the ceiling tiles and you're heading in
the operating room a lot have you been
there and I said doc what are my chances
I had two great neurosurgeons and I'll
never forget I will not mention his name
he's one of the leading neurosurgeons in
the in the world he said senator for
mortality or morbidity and I'm thinking
I swear to God
I'm gonna love it did you know I said
let me put it this way it was a long
road to the operating room I said sister
absolute true story I said what are my
chances of getting off this table and
being completely normal
he saw your chances of living are a lot
better and I said okay what are they he
said well they're there they're in the
35 to 50 percent range and I thought
well seriously there's a born optimist I
said well hell that means 35 out of 150
had 100 make it huh I might as well be
the one I said well what's the most
likely thing that will happen if I if I
live but what he said well the side of
the brain that the first order the first
aneurysm is on controls your ability to
speak now though why the hell didn't
they tell me this before the 88th
campaign could have saved us all a lot
of trouble you know what I mean now I'm
going down the second operation four
months later and because I was on the
other side of my head and this is not
about me but it's about the truth they
put together the same crews you know
they always want the same
anesthesiologist the same team if
they've done an operation on you and so
there was a great guy named dr. Hart
military he had been transferred from
Reed down to Texas and they brought him
back and he's the anesthesiologists and
I'm going down now this operation under
98% use because it hasn't bled at all
they told me this was going to and so
trying to make me feel better the doc
kidding the neurosurgeon looked at me
and said it looked down at me he said
senator do you know why neurosurgeon
said the biggest he goes of Medicine
said no I don't know he said who in the
hell else would going to the brain was
such confidence known as little as they
know about it
and I thought about that for a second
and decided to stop thinking about it
but all kidding aside there's so much we
don't know so much we don't know
in fact Rick Kennedy and I believe the
same way the possibilities are immense
we don't know what they are they're
immense and that's why the president has
asked for a hundred million dollars to
launch a new initiative to map the human
brain truly the last frontier and the
prospects are overwhelming - the very
thing we're most concerned about about
mental health look but we can't do any
of this alone and it's not uh it's not
in the province of government alone
that's why we need you and I want to
thank Valerie Jarrett understand my
staff for reaching out to all of you
putting this together
you're the ones are able to reach
millions of Americans through all forms
of the media it's not just Glencoe sand
Bradley it's you all have significant
reach well you teach our children you
treat our patients you minister to the
faithful and I want to take this
opportunity to thank all of you in this
room individuals and organizations like
for the commitments you've made and
those who who have been ahead of the
curve as most of you in this room had
been ahead of the curve - my friend and
he really is my friend John - Georgia I
just wish I had more kids needing to get
into Georgetown I might have a shot now
although more Biden's have gone to
Georgetown everybody wants to
acknowledge I told my she least name is
sidewalk after me yourself
but I want to thank you John for the
Jack for the for the efforts you made to
integrate the conversations about mental
health and wellness into the curriculum
and and students lives as undergraduates
it's a serious guy hope more I hope more
university's campuses replicate the
program you've put in place and I also
want to thank he's not here but my good
friend Gordon Smith Gordon is and I
serve the United States Senate as he
will tell you we're here we've been
close friends and when he went through
what is probably the most frightening
and horrible prospect any parent could
face of losing his his son to suicide he
unlike a lot of us who had not the same
loss but loss of a child he had the
courage to relive it every day by
speaking out because make no mistake all
of you know this every time Gordon Smith
stands up to talk about this issue it
comes home immediately it is not a
distant memory tractor-trailer killing
my wife and daughter is not a distant
memory every time talked about highway
safety it is not a distant memory every
time you show up at a funeral it is not
a distant memory and I want to publicly
acknowledge his courage the courage to
take a terrible tragedy happened to him
they've provide provide help provide
help to other parents other families so
they may be spared the agony that his
family endured and now he is
representing a National Association of
Broadcasters and I don't think it's an
accident that
concluded that National Public Health
Service campaign to reduce the stigma
around mental illness is part of their
obligation as well so I thank them but I
also thank Gordon for what he's doing
and in another context although this was
part of it I met with the
representatives of the video game
industry they've agreed that they're
going to engage in public health and
public service announcements about
mental health but to all of you the
faith groups the school groups of health
care groups so many others thank you for
your commitment and your dedication to
this essential work my mom were here
God loved her she'd look at you and say
you're doing God's work
no you really are you're doing God's
work because what a lonely lonely lonely
feeling I have a friend who passed away
my college roommate who was having real
problems with his son with mental
illness and I'll never forget what he
said them he said Joe it was this is a
big strapping guy he was we played ball
together at Delaware he was a big fella
from Buffalo New York all-city tough guy
and I'll never forget him saying to me
Joe I feel I'm frightened I said what it
frightened about Don he said I feel like
I'm gonna make up the kid's name because
I don't wanna I feel like I feel like
Johnny is in the end of a string this is
the metaphor I stuck with me mine ever
since he said it he's on the end of a
string and he's out there in space Anna
and I'm afraid I'm not afraid I'm afraid
if I tug it too hard the string will
break and I'll lose him forever forever
it's how a lot of people feel the child
is of a string their husband is of a
string their wife is on a string they
don't know what to do
that's a tug too hard they're afraid it
will break they'll be lost forever so
let's use this moment let's use this
moment to send a message to tens of
millions Americans especially the young
people on the parents of young people
all over this country there's nothing
nothing to be ashamed of if you're
struggling with mental issues or if your
child is or your spouse or your friend
it's okay it's okay to talk about it
it's okay to ask for help it's okay to
acknowledge that it is frightening it's
okay to help a friend it's okay to
intervene it's okay to take a chance to
get help and most importantly the
significant portion of the cases that we
could intervene and help and there is
help it works what we know so much what
people are suffering through is able to
beat manage death it's able to be
managed
millions of people live with high
cholesterol
millions of people live with diabetes
millions of people live with cancer
millions of people live with
life-threatening diseases and thanks to
the docs and nurses out there and
research are able to manage their lives
so many millions more could manage their
lives and with your help and a little
bit of time as my Grandpop would say the
grace of God and the good will of the
neighbors and the creek not rising
there is help so let me conclude by
saying I genuinely mean it I mean it
from the bottom of my heart you can't
help change fundamentally change the way
we deal with mental health problems in
this country so god bless you all and
may God protect our troops thank you
progress on the five